i'm just curious about jaden and how you
got your start oh sure well i went to
columbia law school and for the past
eight years i've been a nonprofit lawyer
and that's led me here i'm not gonna lie
i didn't know much about you but you
seem cool ah thank you very much wanna
thank me with your mouth oh oh my what a
crowd you have your face you know what
she do what she do that's how my fans
are but i'm really excited yes that was
a clip from freeform's latest comedy
everything's trash and we have creator
executive producer writer and star
phoebe robinson with uh
that's just for that show yeah i know i
wear a lot of hats
i'm in demand i'm the leader a crowd
pleaser
that's amazing that you do i mean let's
talk about everything's trash i was
telling you i actually watched the show
on my own before i even knew we were
doing this interview one cause i'm a
huge fan but also i knew you were coming
up with something funny and i was
laughing out loud girl oh good i feel
like a lot of fans are loving it if it
was on love or listed it'd be described
as charming
[Music]
what has been the fan response for you
like for this show it's been really good
people are really excited about it
people love the relationship between
myself and jayden um played by jordan
carlos he plays my brother on the show
because i really just wanted to have a
show that celebrated sibling
relationships because my older brother
means so much to me you popped out your
boob and told people to vote for my
rival it fell out
okay
and i got caught up my bet i am sorry so
as i mentioned in the intro you have a
long list of things that as as a part of
this show i mean you created it you're
starting it you're executive producing
are you like me where it's a lot easier
for you to juggle a bunch of balls in
the air than like someone just toss you
one
yeah i think i like the challenge
because i think each thing requires
different skills for me so it's been a
lot of fun i definitely am exhausted
and i'm just like i was just carb
loading eating sandwiches so like before
we started shooting i'm like i'm just
gonna peloton all the time and then we
started shooting i just ate sandwiches
so i undid all the pellet towel work
yeah but i think it was worth it so
worth it and you need that energy okay
you need that energy for this show um
you know i was curious because obviously
you have come from the podcast world you
live in new york just like phoebe the
character in this show how much of your
own life is this show inspired by yeah i
mean in my early 30s in new york i was
running around eating dollar pizza you
know dating the wrong dudes and like
really struggling with like dead and
everything so that's really true to life
and um i loved podcasting and so i
really just wanted that to be the
foundation of the show and just take it
from there being broke doesn't mean
you're a bad person
it means that life is freaking hard has
it been fun for you to relive some of
those early moments in your career or
life yeah i mean so episode three is
when i go canvassing for my brother and
i when i graduated from pride institute
in
shisha that year
um yeah uh 2006 i campaigned for tom
swazi when he was running against elliot
spitzer and so i was like 21 just
knocking on doors and phone baking i
thought that would be really fun to have
in the show that's okay let's focus up
go out there crush it and get a bunch of
signatures that's so awesome i mean you
know what's so amazing about this show
is that there is your character and your
brother and you know when we meet phoebe
she's a podcast host and producer
her life is you know is a little messy
yeah you know her brand is irreverent
but her brother is running for public
office so where does phoebe's journey go
the rest of the season what can you
tease what i could tease is that you
know phoebe and jayden are gonna bump
heads um we meet hamilton in the first
episode and he's gonna you know be
around for some things and season um and
the fashion's really fun the hair is
really great yeah you know i got some
fun wigs and everything so let's be like
sexy there's a lot of shenanigans my
brother is like i love the show but no
more kissing scenes and i'm like i
kissed someone like almost every episode
that's right okay we gotta find love in
the city too right
i love that that's the part that i can
relate to i'm like oh man kissing frogs
you know to get to the one i love it i
am a free-spirited young woman who wears
head wraps when i'm having sex because
some dudes are not worth sweating them
edges out over okay
okay phoebe obviously the show's called
everything's trash i want you to tell me
right now what are the top three things
that are trashed to you oh
the top three things that are trash to
me that's a great question i am going to
say
or you can even give me one i think
diets are trash i think we need to stop
with it like just eat what you want to
eat work off you want to work out
because i think we take the pressure on
it's like everyone looks good the second
thing
adult acne
i'm still getting it really i don't
understand
from over here it's flawless yeah thank
you there was coverage there's a team of
scientists i thought you know what i
mean but it's like i am 37 how am i
still getting acne that part that's not
cute we gotta fix that uh
right and i would say number three
people
on the subway
who
don't put
earphones in so they're just watching
videos and we're all now watching out
loud yeah out loud don't do it that's a
very east coast thing you know that's
not happening here we're all in our cars
listening to your podcast
but dan they don't use their earbuds no
so and it's like i don't want to hear
you like listening to a podcast or what
have you it's too much so phoebe in the
show is a podcast producer any celebs on
your bucket list that you would like to
have be a guest star on the show as a
guest on the podcast oh
i think the rock would be fun just
because he's a good sense of humor and i
think tv phoebe would try and shoot her
shot with him can you imagine yeah
that would be amazing i feel like you
should also try to recruit whoopi
goldberg i mean you were just fresh off
the view where she was just she was
really helping you shoot your shot with
michael b jordan i know well here's the
thing it's like guys i don't i think
he's hot i don't really want to date him
i don't want to date an actor but he
seems like a lot i think i'm a pretty
lovable guy actually you know for fans
like me who have been following you on
instagram i'm a proud member of thought
niche okay thought nation and your
thirsty thursday post have me hollering
every time just because they're so well
thought out oh thank you so funny and
like do you cut those videos yourself no
my social media team uh swim social they
cut the videos and i just write they
crush it and i just i'm like i'm gonna
write all my horny little thoughts you
know
i'm curious have any of the men that you
have highlighted on thirsty thursdays
ever responded or reached out or maybe
even slid into the dm milo ventimiglia
slid into my dms and was like thank you
so much for this post and i was like oh
thank you for being good sport he was
like no it was so fun and funny and i
really appreciate it i was like milo so
that was like really cool you know why
that's a big deal right i don't think
he's that social on social media
yeah so it was really nice he was like
yeah mandy moore show so many posts so i
looked at it i was like thank you mandy
mandy moore and whoopi goldberg got your
back
[Music]
i love it all right so so much more to
come with everything trash what can you
tease like what's one word you would
describe the rest of this season oh
can i do two sexy mess
yeah that's the brand right yes that's
the brand i'm trying to be yeah
that's what we did thank you so much for
being here thank you i love you you guys
can catch everything's trash wednesdays
on freeform
[Music]
you